what if it wasn't so draw this diagram
with me we're going to look at this in
3d this time what if instead of being
flat along the ground the road was
actually raised like this ok so I know
it looks unsafe but I think about this
for a second I need a bit more space as
we heat draw this with me if you can
imagine this is looking Cylon right but
the road continues off into the distance
ok so it's actually bending around like
this ok in fact just for the sake of it
let's actually bend all the way around
yeah you get the idea ok oh yeah so in
behind here there we go you can see this
is kind of like this curved around
triangular prism ok now this is what we
call a baked track and this is an
embankment right so part of its been
raised now let's think about why this is
going to be helpful remember I asked you
about the normal force in which way it
was prepared well at the moment the
normal force is just vertical ok but we
spent all the time this morning looking
at all these kinds of weed conical
pendulum and thinking about the law
enforcement where it's facing where is
the normal force tracy if my car was
like a point like that the answer is
it's yet offered that angle right so you
can actually draw in your non force like
this it's going to be at 90 degrees and
the wonderful thing about thing about
this is that because it's offered an
angle now you're like I have to resolve
forces but that's the point the fact
that we have to resolve forces means
part of the force was and still is
heading up out of the page
but where's the other part of force it's
going into the center of the circle and
that's exactly what I want right I want
this heading in because now I don't need
just friction right or nada I don't have
just friction I've got this also
contributing right so this is like the
horizontal component of the normal
here's the vertical component of the
normal you can go ahead to penny or
whatever angle you've got here for
example suppose the angle was called
feet up and on the basis of this angle
at some particular speed and it's some
particular angle this force is going to
contribute exactly what I need in order
to stay in the turn right in fact at an
optimum speed there will be no no
friction required which is perfect that
means my tires will walk slow guy okay
and I can make it at a decent speed
around the edge so I want to understand
two things I want to understand number
one what what are the forces governing
this that doesn't make this work and
number two what if like presumably you
know cars not going to be able to
precisely maintain its forces all the
way around well she's going to go up
what's going to go down some crazy guy
some crazy guys going to look at that
and say 55 challenge extensive right
it's a [ __ ] they gonna scream around
all you know there's also gonna be
someone who ignores that it's going to
slow or they're like the old cars just
not going to make it to have sufficient
flossing around one is it going to be
the forces that govern the situation and
that's all of what main facts are about
that's that's the sum total of bank
track questions are about ok so here I
actually do this this is like the setup
now we're going to knuckle down we're
going to do the force is just like we
did this morning okay so we need a few
extra sort of labels on this diagram and
then we like you're going to draw quite
few diagrams okay ah you've got this
angle theta here something else that's
important is the radius of this circle
because of course even if we regardless
of whether talking me in terms of em r
omega squared or MV squared on are you
need to know the radius of the circle of
this term
often like the lay of the land aside for
you you know what kind of an archaeal
road is going to go through okay and
then you get to decide okay well what
should my embankment be that corresponds
to this radius okay so i'm just going to
label that ha now this angle theta this
angle theta is often defined by well
you've got the width of a road let's
let's go this same angle fever of here
you've got the width of the road
probably money has decided how many
lanes your car rather your road is going
to get to be okay so it's like okay
government can afford to do three lanes
say that's a normal kids to state sort
of thing where you're going to get back
tracks like this so therefore the width
of this road is defined okay so maybe if
i call this with your D for distance I
then might have the question as a row
designer if I have a certain distance
here which is the width of the road
that's defined and like the geography of
this area has tell me what kind of an
arc radius I'll have then the question
for me is well how steep should I make
this right and that will depend on what
about Abby Ted change by how much I
maybe invade right so this height here
might be the thing that i can define in
order to get the desired feet are that
fits the desired width of the road and
the radius of the actual turn based on I
don't say a 110 kilometers per hour
speed limit what if i want people be
able to take this turn without having a
slow speed down and it's going to be the
optimist treat to go around not too
sharp lots of shower okay so step one
we're going to here's a little something
for you we're going to resolve forces
without friction
and in brachet brackets what I want you
to write is optimum speed remember i
said to you over here right there will
be some perfect speed such that this
song this normal force the orientation
of the road the bank track is exactly
going to contribute this MV squared
heart that'll be really really nice ok
so at some speed it'll do that and I
don't need any friction to keep me in
which is what i needed otherwise ok so
i'm going to need to have work out
what's going on with this diagram so i'm
going to draw it a bit bigger and i'm
going to draw the same kinds of lines on
there to actually resolve what's
happening ok so I'm just considering my
car as a point there in the middle I've
got the normal force heading off at
right angles all right in in the middle
and now I want to work out horizontal
and vertical
that's a bit high
okay now let's do a bit of geometry here
i'm going to use this theta here let's
define as the angle of the embankment if
i put that in over here how do i get it
inside my force resolution diagram where
does it actually belong any suggestions
yeah fantastic so if this is I mean this
is flat right so there you go ultimate
angles here and here okay so i'm going
to fit a tiny feet up in there now since
this is the normal I've got right angles
there yeah so where would you like me to
put an angle in the diagram and what's I
should a bit I'm inside the rectangle
now put it depending on how many steps
you want to skip the most direct thing I
can see is just this adjacent I just the
adjacent one that's going to be a
compliment angling right a compliment so
it's going to be PI on 2 minus theta and
that therefore means ok we'll have a
feed here and I've got there you can you
happy yeah okay now on the basis of
those let's have a look look at what
your aunt was our let's take the our
horizontal force first the horizontal
component which trig ratio is going to
connect theta the puzzle of component
and the normal look it's saying right
side theta is opposite on hypotenuse x n
on n so if I just super fan you can see
quickly side VR that'll give me my
horizontal code right and in the same
way vertical component will be nice Tina
cool as much as you ready ok so I have a
look have I a trooper my accounted for
all of the forces in my day presumably
I'm like on a planet with mass so
therefore um the earth and our part are
pulling toward each other there's the
weight force right so that's going to be
M G headed damn it ok how am I accounted
for everything now
wait what do you think like that yep so
don't you have to consider them I'm
asking the question how they accounted
for everything the rewind reran ruined
remember when we consider this before
black we said in order to make any turn
you're going to need to have this kind
of force okay so i said well under
normal circumstances friction is the
only thing but ty is the only thing
pushing you this way right but what I'm
trying to do is consider in some perfect
situation where I'm going around with
the exact right Spain so that it's the
embankment that's pushing the over okay
so i do i need to do with friction no no
I will I will but in this simplified
situation I don't have to get